on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook with our censor
knife crime and shoplifting are epidemic
levels how do we tackle a deadly
breakdown and respect for authority
Bambi's on ice because of s snowflakes
Disney's remake of the cartoon classic
could cut his famous death scene because
you guessed it it's too triggering for
sensitive young modern audiences
business exactly the kind of pandering
that makes everyone so sensitive in the
first place we'll discuss
thus the Superstar powerlifter April
Hutchinson face has been kicked out of
her spawn because she had the audacity
to complain about competing with
biological men tonight she's speaking
out she joins me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan accents we spend a lot of time in
this country ringing our hands about
American gun violence how can this be
happening in 2023 we asked repeatedly
tragedy after tragedy why does it seem
like nothing ever gets done well guns
aren't widely available in Britain but
knives are and we increasingly have a
deadly and terrifying recurring problem
of our own last week 15 year old Elian
andam was stabbed to death at a bus stop
in Croydon London she was just trying to
get to school last week there were two
other stabbings of that one tiny corner
of London and yesterday the capital has
a specific and serious problem with nice
Prime it's not just London a 16 year old
boy was stabbed to death in Luton last
week five teenagers were wounded in two
shocking knife attacks there on the same
day this weekend there was a triple
stabbing in Halifax two young people a
day
121 the other just 19 to member stand to
death in Leeds belly and day passes
without more of this Bloodshed this is
the kind of response we get every time
my number one priority and I think the
teacher at night is the safety of
londoners so it's not just about
policing it's not just about stop and
search so that's fantastically important
it's also about wrapping your arms
around the kids and putting them on the
right track the death of anyone through
an act of violence is an appalling
tragedy I want to say how shocked and
saddened I am that three people have
lost their lives
just words isn't it just word salad
putting arms around them
is that going to stop kids stabbing each
other it's not is it we'll know that for
all the condolences and the talk of
getting tough the fact is that people
who want to hurt us no longer fear the
consequences if they do police numbers
are down budgets have been slashed
they've stopped taking everyday crimes
even remotely seriously when the Home
Secretary announced last month that
police must investigate all thefts was
supposed to be a huge Innovation my
question would be what the hell are they
doing before shoplifting is now out of
control in Britain still thefts have
more than doubled and they're only
getting worse in America it's the same
issue emboldened by absurd policies on
not Prosecuting minor offenders
shoplifting especially of the steaming
variety with dozens and dozens of
shoplifters entering a store at one time
has become an epidemic
this little wonder that Donald Trump got
Novation over the weekend for saying
this
and we will immediately stop all of the
pillaging and theft very simply if you
rob a store you can fully expect to be
shot as you are leaving that store
I don't think shooting shoplifters is
the right response I don't think guns
are the right response but there does
need to be a response we're dealing with
a systematic breakdown of fear and
respective Authority at the very same
time as a failing economy means
desperate people are more willing to
Rick to risk more the result is chaos
fear and tragedy
it's got to stop so the question is how
autonomy knows my pack talk to me
contributor Esther cracker the Socialist
author Grace Blakely political
journalist Ava Santina and for the U.S
perspective the former wrestler and Fox
News Star Tyrus well welcome to all of
you Tara let me start with you
what is causing all this in America
young people invading stalls with total
impunity because they know there's no
real consequence uh here we have an
endemic now of knife crime young kids
stabbing each other America has
obviously ongoing huge gun violence
problems the common theme in all of them
is there is a in my opinion a smaller
and smaller estimation of other people
carrying out all this stuff that there
will be any real accountability for it
well and you're brilliant as always but
I here's the thing we got two things in
common we have knives in England and we
have guns in America two very different
violent weapons
so what we have in common is we have
awful people we have horrible parenting
grandparents are afraid of their
grandchildren a complete breakdown of of
our consequences for children which
starts at home we've got the bulldozer
parents in America where if a kid does
something at school they want the
teacher fired not the child uh punished
so and you can see that when they're
growing up and now you have no
consequences when they are arrested
they're released in America if you steal
I think it's like 500 to 900 American uh
it's not considered a crime anymore so
that's the the biggest problem is that
we have to start realizing it's not the
weapons and the utilities they use if we
took knives away in England they'd
probably use trucks and cars or bats
it's horrible people we have awful
people in in this first world uh that we
and they have so many things they can do
they don't have to work hard for
anything and there's no consequences
these are first world problems coming
back to bite us uh in countries that are
successful because in in third world
countries and things like that that when
you steal when you do horrible things
there are real consequences you steal a
lot you lose a hand in some cases so
just the idea of that will refrain
people but right now our kids across the
sea in America basically feel they can
do whatever they want and there's no
parenting it's horrible parenting right
all right Grace I could see a lot of the
facial expressions going on there
have always been horrible people you
know it's very easy to look at the
situation and say oh it's just because
we've suddenly been giving birth to
loads more horrible people that
obviously isn't the case if we look at
this you know just objectively if we
look at the facts if we look at the
statistics the studies on what causes
violent crime the single biggest
predictor across the board of levels of
violent crime across time and space is
inequality why it's not just because
people are poorer and they want you know
to access more stuff that is a problem
it's because in a society that denies
particularly young men access to
advancement then violent crime becomes
something of a status symbol this is
borne out across sociological studies
across time and space it becomes you
know there's an incentive to kind of
steal kill someone then to steal their
trainers because it becomes a status
symbol I
touched on a point and saying that in
third world countries you don't
necessarily have this problem because
they're actual social consequences which
I think is an important point he touched
on when I was a kid growing up in Ghana
if you stole something in our
neighborhood it doesn't matter who who
finds out whether it's your neighbor or
someone else once your your family gets
to know there will be consequences
sometimes your neighbor might discipline
you the issue here is a breakdown of
legal and social consequences and that's
what we're missing it has to be
ostracization and actual social
consequences for stealing but it also
has to be legal penalties real ones I
agree I'm gonna say I have come round I
mean Tara's talked about third world
countries you look at someone like
Singapore or Hong Kong I've walked the
streets of these places at midnight
right you just don't get this kind of
stuff there because the penalties if you
do are severe and I keep being told by
the wishy-washy Brigade Ava look you
know you you can't be too tough on these
kids you've got to be actually why why
don't we just say right the next time a
young kid is caught with a knife life on
the street they get 10 years in prison I
can tell you it would soon stop and it
may sound like I'm creating I've morphed
into a right-wing headbanger I can
assure you most people in this country
would share that sentiment so why aren't
we doing tougher things like that well I
don't know the extreme of your argument
is we turn into Saudi Arabia and then we
just throw away anyone who might you
know look like they're committing a
crime or then we execute them I'm not
saying that I'm talking about people
not for cutting up their cheddar cheese
point there about 10 years well we've
got a prison system at the moment that
doesn't work it doesn't rehabilitate
people and at the moment we are turfing
people out sorry we're throwing them
into prison and they're coming out the
other side and we are they're not
rehabilitating they're going back to
Commitment how are you going to stop how
are you going to stop the kids I think I
think it goes back to what Grace is I
think it's a social issue I think that
we've got to really tackle inequality
you know we've got to look at this long
term rather than thinking what's the
short-term solution and throw everyone
like you know lock everyone up and throw
away the key
okay before we look inequality seems to
me what with great respect one of those
vacuous generic terms like a sort of
catch-all excuse for what is going on
here I know lots of kids who come from
poor backgrounds who do not go around
stabbing people because their parents
and this can apply by the way to to
lower class people to middle class
people to so-called upper-class people I
went to a fee paying school till I was
13 then State uh comprehensive School
I've seen all manner of people right and
parents the common theme of kids that
behaved well or at least felt shame and
accountability if they were caught doing
bad things was strong parenting right
teachers yes and Authority yes but
actually strong parents I just explained
to you the that's not about equality no
it is it's about the mechanism through
which equality of inequality affects
violent crime you know it's not about
equality you can say for example you
know
um not everyone not every kid who's been
in institutional care is going to end up
on the streets but we know statistically
speaking that children who've been an
institutional
what I'm saying is there is a clear and
causal link between the things that
happen to you as a child that accounts
for because things like whether or not
you're in a strong Community whether or
not you're in a strong family but also I
would say I would say what happens to
you I say things like successive
governments labor and conservatives
selling off playing fields by the Dozen
absolutely cutting back on sport cutting
back I did a documentary on hoodies
right kids that wear hoodies and commit
a lot of crime and a lot of these kids
when I interviewed them said well there
are no like youth clubs anymore right
they just shut them all down so there's
nothing else to do they're getting bored
so it's also the Internet isn't it like
I don't want to sound like some sort of
like Draconian figure but you know it is
the rise of social media and if you were
in an algorithm and you're on tiktok or
Instagram that is promoting violence to
you you do sit in an echo oh let me
bring in Taurus do you be listening to
this Taurus I think you want to add some
more on this
hey let me just say that let me say this
again she has absolutely no idea what
she's talking about without due respect
which one because it could be one yeah
it's the community that's what has
broken down they're spoiled everyone
spends all their time on social media
and Facebooks and they say oh it's in
quality I grow up in Lynn Massachusetts
ghetto slum USA but you know what we had
strong families and parents and we're
poor but we didn't act poor we worked
hard we paid our dues and we got things
together now everyone makes excuses if
your kid's bad he's not a bad child
you're not a bad parent he has something
wrong with him that you can't correct so
it has nothing to do with inequality
that's just a good answer from first
world virtue signaling at least to say
because you can't fix that everything
that band had some form of inequality
it's ridiculous I agree with you and I
mean it's
raised by lazy people it's high time
Grace Blakely School the First World
Elite as well so I've been waiting for
that taunt uh look I got I'm gonna say I
agree
simply saying it's inequality
look how tough I am
hold your hands
how do you explain if it's all about
inequality that so many people who have
very little in life in this country do
not commit these crimes because it is
about a whole set of factors that
determine you know the the way in which
you were raised and then the kind of
characters look again
you know that children who grow up in
institutional care are much more likely
to then go out onto the streets end up
on the streets and the homeless end up
taking drugs end up interacting with the
criminal justice system that isn't to
say that every kid who has a you know
who has institutional care is going to
end up that way but we know that if you
don't experience the last Point
Community Support the biggest Point here
is culture because I can I can paint two
different pictures here if we look at
the black community in the UK you
actually look at the the sort of uh
um the rates of criminality amongst
black African children
um compared to Black Caribbean children
and there's a huge disparity and one of
the biggest reasons because of culture
because some kids kids in one particular
group grow up and with church girl and
church-going families with strong values
you know if you go and carry a knife
around your Nigerian mother finds you
you will probably get slapped across the
face and you have other um the other
side of the um the spectrum that don't
actually have that and you can see huge
disparities there so it actually comes
down to culture I don't disagree with
you but the question is how do we then
build supportive change
in communities I agree we've just said
the same thing Public Health but you
also know that you also have to you have
to penalize uh criminality in a very
severe way there is no reason why
someone should be able to get carry a
knife
and then they come out the other side
and they find themselves homeless and
they don't have any money
but you are going to commit another
crime in the US you can get literally
shot or asphyxiated just for failing for
police cars
you can you know what worries me about
the life crime it's getting worse here
and they're acting with more impunity
and more kids are carrying knives so at
some point we've got as a society T yes
we can lecture the Americans about their
gun violence and I've done that many
times
I think it's nuts they don't do more I
also think it's nuts we don't do more
about knife violence here I mean look
the Americans literally give police
forces so much money they give them like
assault rifles these massive weapons you
know weapons that are used in literal
states of war and yet that isn't solving
the problem
all right let's move on to another
active uncontrollable violence so uh
Bambi is being really done and uh and
it's after the break apparently we're
going to talk about Bambi and why the
death scene Bambi's mum cops it is now
being written out because you guessed it
people are gonna get triggered little
sensitive snowflakes can't deal with an
actual death God help them what would
they do in the real world when people
actually die for real
we'll debate that after the break
[Music]
foreign
Again by Jordan Peterson I get a sense
of somebody quite angry with the state
of the world I'm absolutely appalled
that the globalist utopian elitists
would sacrifice the poor to save the
planet this war on the patriarchy what
are your thoughts on that females who
are anti-social use reputation salvaging
bullying and exclusion to gain their
narcissistic pathway forward how do you
feel about that influence that you have
you better be careful we're coming for
your children there buddy let's just get
it on the table do you believe in God I
don't think that's anybody's business
for some reason you're reluctant to say
it's too complicated an issue to be
dealt with like that now you did it
again you got me again god well this
what could be worse than dying being a
prison guard at Auschwitz how much sex
is Optimum depends on how the date goes
man you should know that this is so
interesting maybe it's worth sticking
around for and trudging through the
misery just to see how it ends
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and I said so
that is a brilliant interview with
Jordan Peterson as a year ago I first
interviewed him but as tomorrow night
and Wednesday night it's a double header
the first task is me and Jordan
one-on-one you just saw some of the
clips from that it's it's fantastic uh
with the most brilliant mind really and
fascinating mind and a challenging mind
so whatever you think of him tune in and
you'll be surprised and then his
daughter joins us she's become a huge
Star as well Michaela and part two on
Wednesday night will be the two of them
together and what's really interesting
about that is the way they interact with
each other so a two-parter the Petersons
uh two of the most famous and
influential people in the world right
now uh and on Thursday and I'm gonna
surprise him on Tuesdays I did later in
the program well Disney's ban B has led
his victim of the woke wall on culture
screenwriter had to remake the classic
says the movie's most famous scene in
which Bambi's mother sadly dies could be
scrapped is this triggering for modern
day parents and their children she
elaborated in this interview with
Collider
what's interesting about Bambi to me is
it absolutely is a classic because it's
such a gorgeous film it's a little bit
different Tempo than I think
um modern audiences are used to and I
also think there's a there's there's a
treatment of the not to spoil the plot
but there's a there's a there's a
treatment of the mom dying that I think
some kids some parents these days are
more sensitive about than they were and
yes in the past and I think that's one
of the reasons that they haven't shown
it to their children but our take on it
was
um did give a little bit more of a scope
to it and I just think that to be able
to bring it to life for kids these days
in a way that maybe they relate to a
little bit more would would be of
service to the original
I should get a favor when I would have
venison for my dinner tonight children
are facing an epidemic of anxiety
apparently maybe because we feel the
need to protect them so ridiculously
much over time now from Bambi to discuss
this I'm joined by our key host Tommy
Lee authored a case for Council culture
Ernest Owens well welcome to both of you
from across the pond all right Ernest
you've defended the indefensible a few
times on this program but come on for
goodness sake we're going to try and
airbrush the reality of Bambi's mum
getting slotted what's the matter with
you
well there's nothing wrong with me I
think that the reality is that as
Society evolves we should also think
about you know the impact you know we
are in a different type of world now you
know there's a lot of violence on TV
there's a lot of of grotesqueness and I
think that this classic film should be
seen by a with a different perspective
for kids I think that the death scene
isn't necessarily the thing that they
should be fixated on I think there's
something to be said about how you know
children deal with death and death
scenes compared to adults like you and I
and I think that this is a very smart
move I think it's a move that is
considerate I think that it shows
progress and I think to be honest you
know I think some parents would rather
have that conversation with their
children say their home rather than
having these things you know kind of
traumatized what's next you're going to
remake jewels and make sure this shot
doesn't need anyone okay someone's
triggered and can't go swimming it's
nuts uh Tommy this is just nuts isn't it
it's nuts and I would also like to say I
wish they would stop remaking Disney
Classics we talked about this I think a
couple months back this remake the Snow
White they have to make it for woke
audiences does Disney really not have
any other ideas can they not come up
with anything new that they have to
remake all the classics so that's my
first point on it and second of all I
believe in protecting children I just
find it quite interesting that the same
woke liberals that are worried about
this hunting scene and Bambi have no
problem exposing children to gay porn an
lgbtq themes telling them that they are
born in the wrong body encouraging them
to be non-binary I mean really I'm
waiting for this Bambi remake to have
Bambi as a trans deer or maybe the
mother died from climate change so again
the things at the left and the Liberals
are triggered by always astounds me I
think that there are far worse things
you can expose children to that the left
is exposing children to then a hunting
scene that's actually a reality of life
especially here in the United United
States with a lot of hunters love it or
hate it that is a fact of where we are
in this country and I think in many
places around the world do you know what
Ernest I think you've been persuaded by
that argument I can see you nodding away
furiously
I think this is ridiculously homophobic
and transphobic I think for starters I'm
gay and me being here talking isn't
exposing children to anything but if I
was to pull out a gun as a hunter and
shoot a a deer for kids to see I think
that's going to cause more harm to a
child than just me just basically
honestly
um I think it's ridiculous to make that
conflation
coaching porn to a a dare being killed
when in reality no one is actually
promoting gay porn no one from the left
is encouraging that for children and to
conflate those things in that way it's
intellectual dishonest and mature and
problematic Ernest we literally had Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves redone
recently and the airbrushed all the
dwarves out of the movie right because
apparently they want to be inclusive the
people that didn't include were the
actual dwarves who then now a lot of
work this is where this low version you
know what you you know what you could do
you could rather than whining about new
things you can just go and stay stuck in
1939 and watch this Disney animated
films love too you can do that I would
love to be honest and other people can
watch and other people I would love to
and then I can watch my Disney films but
Ernest then I can watch my Disney films
without people like you ruining them
right and trying to pertain to some kids
mum being killed peers I hear that
pierce I missed the old Pierce board and
I used to interview Beyonce and hang out
with the Liberals in Hollywood and be
nice yeah so now I have this new Pierce
when it's Unleashed and guess what
there's there's value in both for some
people no I want to have two things at
the same time I'm one Earnest I'm one of
these ostracized liberals where I used
to think I was liberal and then the woke
left came along and I realized actually
by their yardstick I'm right at the
tiller the hun because I think
everything they do wrecks Society I
really do and when you go back and
remake a Disney classic and you you
presume that kids can't deal with the
death of a deer I think you've all gone
mad
peers you're proving my point things
evolve right and so there's a new
version of you that you think has
evolved and this Creator who's creating
the Bambi film thinks this can evolve
and this could be people that say I miss
the oh no honest you're missing the
point the old show nothing days
we let two things exist just to be clear
I haven't evolved at all I'm exactly the
same as I always was it's just the
people I used to agree with have broadly
gone mad uh Tommy the problem with this
is It's a real slippery slope I think
once you start going after every classic
it's a bit like every historical figure
they're all flawed there's no American
president in history who won't be
canceled by this yardstick there's no
founding father that won't be canceled
there is no films there's no hang on
you're dead hang on Ernest this is the
fictional film it does the fictional
film the baby's Mother's Day to Earnest
wake up
I also
tell me I think that there are you know
more problematic things to have to
explain to Children besides the death of
animals I think that that is the circle
of life I think we learned that in The
Lion King we learned that from a lot of
Disney Classics but you know in the last
segment you were talking about the
Looting and the rioting and the
shoplifting kids are exposed to that
every single day certainly in the United
States and I don't hear liberals worried
about them being exposed to that they
call that Justice right but they're
worried about a scene in which Bambi's
mom dies I mean the priorities again to
me are so astounding yeah I completely
agree uh the reaches to me outstanding
the reach the reach you're conflating
looters to people who don't want a Bambi
scene like this is a reach
you should be stressed let's leave it on
a reach and it's always good to catch up
with you Tommy great to see you too
thank you both very much indeed all
right uh my pack he was sort of
convulsing the three of you about this
debate at the heart of this debate lies
my basic belief that we are we're
covering our kids in so much cotton wool
they are woefully ill prepared for the
real world and I'll explain why when we
brought in participation prizes for
sports day right all that means is kids
do not learn what losing involves what
not winning involves you don't get
participation prizes in the real world
you win you lose you lose a job you get
a job whatever there's no reality to
this now all the films are being
sanitized because apparently kids can't
deal with it I'm fine I watched all
these films it didn't turn me into some
corrupted mass murder or make me flake
out it just it was a film that had that
sad moment and your heart goes like that
when you when you watch it what's wrong
with allowing kids to watch the reality
well I don't agree with your first bit
because I you know we actually do have
participation prizes in life and that is
just you know not being that's not being
number one taxes at not all times are
you number one I can tell you in this
game you don't in the media you don't no
one gives you a privacy coming eighth
well last you know maybe I would like
one no no the British press awards for
example nobody no newspaper gets the
wall for coming last can I say on your
second point there you know we actually
already did soften these fairy tales you
know these all originate from Grimm's
Fairy Tales I like the Grimes but you
look at The Little Mermaid and that was
Hans Christian Anderson and it was a
really gruesome tale you know we already
did something I like gruesome Tails yeah
but we already did soften them down so
now my daughter Grace my daughter my
daughter's nearly 12. she writes like
really quite full-on gruesome stuff
right and I think it's fascinating got a
very creative mind very febrile mine
very you know all over the place but she
writes really riveting things but it's
often based on Fantastical stuff right
this is what we all grew up with what
are we trying to pretend the real world
thing at Disney is a marketing genius
because they are in the news every week
every month we've remade this show and
the character is a different race or
we're cutting this scene and it's gonna
really annoy Piers Morgan and it's going
to be all over his show for weeks and
weeks and weeks and weeks and even
though he hates it Piers Morgan is going
to go to the cinema he's gonna watch
that film and everyone who watches his
show he's gonna watch that he's
gonna know that that's coming out again
look and it's going to make us tons and
tons if I can't watch babies
what a Horror Story look I wasn't a fan
of like snow beige and the southern
genderless Widgets or whatever it turned
out to be but but but but I do think the
overarching point is make new stories
for the love of God stop remaking them
and just making them you know yellow and
green and you know having some
one-legged Chinese trans person or
whatever just make you stronger
Ernest was convinced that I have evolved
a new place on this stuff right I
haven't I'm exactly the same person I've
always been but the the sort of the
world that I thought the liberal world
was about has changed so dramatically
this woke stuff is completely mad most
of the time I don't agree I don't think
you would have read your children the
Grimm's Fairy Tales yes
because you would you'd like the soft
version my kids if we play sport we've
played win right I've never given an
inch now the older ones beat me okay
good so they've learned the joy of
beating their dad because I didn't let
them ever win when they were kids I'd
rather beaten 10 nil and let them win or
score a goal I mean part of the problem
with what we were discussing before this
whole knife from epidemic is actually we
do have this society that consistently
tells people they're either winners or
losers yes and how much money they earn
based on whether or not they have a good
car and there are the same people who
end up consistently on top as winners
the same people end up consistently on
top as losers and the people who feel
like they are losers because there are
no paths for them to change their lives
or to change anything about themselves
end up basically taking their Revenge
either on themselves or on the rest of
society that is what you have when you
have a society that is structured
basically by telling people you're worth
something and you're not so in your
world everyone's a winner even if
they're lazy work shy don't put the
shift in they're still Witnesses my
world is a world in which people are
different and cannot be compared by
weird league tables that tell you if you
have more money then you're a better
person I don't I think money's gotten to
do it but it does you know we live in an
incredibly material there are for
example there are brilliant nurses where
money is not going to get paid nothing
money there's no value tell them that
what they're doing isn't worth it money
is not a comparative thing but it is
why do you think people like Andrew
Taylor up there being like Oh I have
loads of guns and loads of Range Rovers
and loads of women Andrew
popular with young men because he is he
is out there for better or worse and I
think there are equal doses of both of
them for better or worse he is a voice
defending young men when actually every
other voice out the moment attacks
Andrew Tate is a voice speaking to men
with status anxiety telling them Society
tells you you're a loser because you
can't get a job and you don't have any
money buy a load of guns abuse women get
a Range Rover and then you'll be worth
something and that's so dumb all right
like that's not how you create a
goodness you need the participation
medals
the inequality in society I think
they'll always be winners and losers and
I think it's the way we handle just to
say that actually we need a society that
doesn't have winners or loses it's not
that we need a society
I now win because I get to stay on the
show you three lose because you're being
removed and yeah you'll invite us back
anyway against my better judgment yes I
will uh lovely to see you all and says
the next power lifter April Hutchinson
faces losing her career but speaking out
on trans competitors in women's sport
powerlifting she's live in the studio
next
foreign
[Music]
Trump yeah look at him fail not working
just because their skin folk don't mean
they're kinfolks do you believe you can
win this war but it's making me cry
again they're trying to force you out
yes I feel betrayed keep it
award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous it was
clearly something of the face of the
world so it was even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katie that would make
her a better princess of wealth because
you're not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election can we yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
[Music]
let it roll
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off charts
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drug you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
[Music]
will I get a better interview roughing
you up a bit will I get the real Zlatan
then you want to play with fire I'll
bring your fire but that will burn you
when I say I am God you think I'm joking
or not you tell me I'm not joking I
could see you playing a bond villain I
would smash James Bond I'm very
expensive I don't work for free at
Guardiola you call them a coward with no
balls he said when you buy me you're
buying a Ferrari
when you score a goal is it better than
sex sex is better whoever thinks
different he has a problem with his sex
you should get help why have you never
asked your partner Elena to marry you I
have Amina ryola who died last year it
was a big loss because he was not only
agent for me he was everything I still
missing we all missing there's only one
thing you got wrong I didn't go towards
I don't do trials no no you don't
understand I don't do trials I'm the
best his own censored
[Music]
talk about two answers that is not
missable exclusive interview Zlatan
Ibrahimovic one of the most charismatic
and best strikers of football has ever
seen retired several months ago this is
his first big interview since then we
had two hours together and we'll run the
highlights of that in a special on
Thursday night and then the whole thing
will be available after that it is a
riveting watch what a character we're
over here I interviewed two former
angling stars who quit the England
women's team over a transgender teammate
they thought had an unfair Advantage the
sports international governing body has
now ruled that male-born competitors
cannot take on women because their
physical power gives them an unfair
Advantage so some common sense again
prevailing in the world of women's sport
but the Fight Continues in many other
women's sports Canadian powerlifter
April Hutchinson has taken a stand
against trans women in her sport facing
a backlash for doing so well now our
videos emerged of her rival and Andrew
is a male to female trans athlete who
holds the women's record in Canada
appearing to mock women for being weak
why is women's bench so bad
I mean not compared to me we all know
that I'm a freak so that doesn't
count and no we're not talking about
Mackenzie Lee she's got little T-Rex
arms and she's like 400 pounds of chest
muscle apparently
I mean standard bench in powerlifting
competition for women I literally don't
understand why it's so bad
well Team Canada power lifter able
Hutcherson joins me now well welcome to
page Wellness says thank you for coming
to the studio
um Ann Andrus who is a biological male
who's transgendered currently holds four
of the five provincial records the
highest deadlift of all ages in Canada
um
if Anna just competed with males then
she would place around 6 000. they're
right there is the inequality the
unfairness that we're seeing in many
sports but particularly a sport like
yours
yeah so you have powerlifting which is
uh pure strength sport males have an
advantage of 60 to 70 percent advantage
over females you hear Anne talking about
the bench press why is bench press so
weak for females we're not designed for
bench press we don't have the the right
muscle mass for a bench press so
therefore we will be weaker when you
hear
her mocking really the whole situation
how does that make you feel
it's it's the whole thing is disgusting
it's disgraceful it's disheartening it
uh even more Discerning that the
Federation allows this to happen I am
the one being punished for speaking
truth yet he can mock females and say
you know call me a bigot uh incite hate
and nothing's being done about that but
I'm the one being silenced by my
Federation what is going to happen to
you
well most recently uh I've been
threatened with suspension uh two weeks
ago I received a letter from my
Federation stating that you cannot call
in a biological male that goes against
the code of ethics you know because in
their policy we do ask that we use
pronouns they don't force you to but
they ask also um but but she is a
biological male I mean I'm perfectly
prepared to call uh Anne her name that
she prefer to be called that's fine but
she's a biological male a transgender
athlete who's now destroying
female competitors in women's sport I
mean to me again but particularly in
this uh powerlifting it's so obvious
that if someone would come six thousand
competing against men but is winning
against women there's the problem
exactly now just recently the strongman
Corporation in Canada we spoke out
against they had a transgender athletes
they actually changed their policy to
create a separate category right so
simple and that's all we've been asking
is for a separate category to me it's
very simple what should happen is you
either compete against your biological
sex so if you're a trans woman you were
compete against biological males as most
of them have done before in sport
massively less successfully it should be
noted or you have a completely new
category easy peasy yeah it could be
that easy but yes because there are far
more people in identifying as men or
women different to their biological sex
these categories would be quite well uh
I would imagine well stopped with people
right there'd be lots of people wanted
to do it no exactly yeah well my
Federation actually I think they've gone
Rogue they've done their own thing
they've created an inclusion policy so
you could identify as a female tomorrow
peers take all the records crush it in
the women's category and then go back to
being a man the next day that I mean
that's something you must say in a
rental over said very early on and she
was accused of being a bigot one of the
biggest lgbtq Advocates probably ever in
sport she was accused of being bigoted I
mean this is the sort of go this is the
sort of
I don't know what you would call it but
it's the instant reaction every time
anyone in your position or Martina or
whatever they raise a concern about this
obvious unfairness if I would call it
cheating I mean just it's cheating to me
it has the same effect as doping right
in the sense it gives somebody an unfair
Advantage we all know this but people
like you brave enough to put your head
of the power but you get shot down and
called bigoted transphobic and so on
well exactly I mean I've been called
that word I don't know how many times
now I am it's not transphobic to ask for
fairness in women's sports it's a word
they use to silence you well I'm not
going to be if you have any problem with
transgender people no not at all not at
all I I have a problem with uh
transgender athletes going into women's
sports or AKA biological men yeah
picking women's Podium spots sponsors
and you never see it the other way
around with trans men exactly never it
doesn't happen because trans Men
actually have an inferior disadvantage
when they compete against biological men
obviously because they're biological
females so there's a reason I always say
is the reason the Olympics you split the
genders up if you didn't if you made it
gender-neutral the next Olympics women
would win about two gold medals if they
were lucky in the entire tournament yeah
well it's the reason why there's
categories I'm in the master so I
compete between 40 and 50 years old yeah
there's people from 50 to 60 there's
Juniors like I could identify as a
junior tomorrow and go crush the Juniors
right exactly and if you had to compete
in your category of 40 to 50 Masters
against only biological males who
identified now as women but have
competed in powerlifting in that
category how would you get on oh false I
think the answers for itself not well so
I mean you wouldn't win anything right
no nothing
so your chances of being able to be
successful in your sport are massively
eroded simply because people with an
unfair physical Advantage have come
along and decided they want to be you
exactly and this particular person and I
mean
he's taking records that
basically people that have been trained
for 10 years haven't even touched a
number like a deadlift of 573 pounds is
unheard of especially by a 40 year old
so are you going to sue the Federation
well I I do have an attorney
um that's in the works right now I do
have to respond to their letter of
disciplinary but it is in the works yes
and I'm actually um raising money right
now for legal fees to pay the lawyers I
think it is ridiculous people like you
are put through this hell for spelling
out the bleeding obvious I do think it's
ridiculous and we keep hammering this on
this program because I think most
right-minded people know how ridiculous
it is and how unfair it is but thank you
for coming in I wish you good luck and
we will keep hammering this drum until
Common Sense prevails in every sport yes
for sure and I just want to uh give you
this as a gift because it is women's
History Month in Canada ah so I made the
shirt
for you keep female sports female I can
let's make this Global as well you know
what I will happily endorse that t-shirt
because they should be and women's uh
rights to fairness inequality should
Trump
stupid allegations of being transphobic
I've no problem with any trans people I
wish them all the very best I want them
to have fairness and equality in their
lives absolutely but not when it erodes
women's rights to fairness inequality
that is just unfair and unequal thanks
for coming in and says the next the
unsolved murder of Tupac Shakur has been
the subject of speculation only 30 years
police have at last arrested in charged
a man for the shooting in Las Vegas in
1996 next to speak to DJ Vlad a man who
have helped who may have helped uncover
the truth by interviewing the suspect
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt vows to make work pay with a
boost to the minimum wage and a
Crackdown on benefit claimants plus
doctors are accused of ripping off the
NHS after pocketing almost eight grand a
shift to cover for striking colleagues
and its Royals the ruskies as Moscow
cyber hackers Target Buckingham Palace
that's all coming up at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook around sense it
was a question that gripped the world
who killed Tupac Shakur the 25 year old
rapper considered one of the most
influential artists of all time was
gunned down in Las Vegas in 1996 well on
Friday Dwayne Keith D Davis was indicted
on one kind of murder was a deadly
weapon in relation to the killing DJ
vladder made you commentator in the
hip-hop industry for years making the
police in Las Vegas asked him to help
their investigation after he interviewed
Keith for his own show and DJ Vlad and
he joins me now pulled out a gun it
looked like he was reaching yeah
okay yeah
did you actually see a gun oh once
you got the region I got the turkey so
someone from your car that's what I
started shooting
at Tupac and shook so Orlando
he leaned over on the one we rode on the
window popped
they were drove on my side I was popping
you know what I'm saying but they was on
the other side right
well DJ Vlad joins me now thank you very
much Dave for joining the show
absolutely thank you for having me I
know you've studied this case uh for so
long and these interviews that you did
uh with keithy they've turned out to be
extremely significant in this
investigation leading in fact to him
being arrested and indicted when you
heard that news how did you feel
well I mean the goal wasn't really to
get anyone arrested it was really just
to get the truth of the matter uh the
story about Orlando Anderson killing
Tupac I've known since around 2007 so
this is was essentially the worst kept
secret in LA everyone knew about it but
there were no arrests there was no
convictions there was no anything there
was no actual proofs there's a lot of
conspiracy theories around it so uh
around 2008 uh when I first heard the
Keefe confession tapes that Greg Hayden
got
um you know then I found out there was a
book that was about to come out uh I got
a hold of KPD and his co-writer and we
scheduled an interview and we just went
from there
he appears to distributed himself in
this interview so in the last one
did you believe he was doing that as you
interviewed him
well I think that he believed that he
had a level of immunity when he did the
proper agreement I also I think at the
time he was saying that he had cancer so
maybe he didn't think he had much time
to live uh so he was just kind of
letting it loose at that point but
um you know it was it was a little bit
crazy that he actually sat down and we
did everything and when I asked him
about it sometimes he would try to dodge
certain questions but ultimately I used
the book as a blueprint so whenever a
question wouldn't get answered I said
well the book said X Y and Z and then at
that point he kind of went along with
the you know what was written in the
book
it's been reported that you have
resisted efforts by the police to hand
over all the unedited tapes is that true
and if so why
yeah it's true I mean ultimately people
that we have on our show
we we don't turn around and cooperate
against those same people with the
police for me just in terms of
business-wise and my ethics and so forth
I just feel there's something wrong so
when Las Vegas Police reached out to me
multiple times I just never responded uh
I think what they did ultimately want
was the raw footage that was an email
that they sent after a couple of phone
calls when unanswered
um ultimately if you know the style of
our footage
everything that we film gets released so
I think there's a little bit of a
barking up the wrong tree situation uh
but maybe they thought there was a
gotcha on there in the footage that was
unreleased which I'm not aware of it
since everything did get released But
ultimately we don't cooperate with the
police and you know we've had situations
where police have tried to get footage
from us and we've had our lawyers step
in and actually block it are you
concerned I mean you know I've done many
interviews including crime interviews
actually over the years there's always a
certain element of concern as an
interview when you stray into that kind
of territory about repercussions from
people involved I mean given there's now
been an indictment here are you worried
about repercussions against you
I don't worry about doing my job I've
been doing uh Vlad TV for 15 years now
we've covered a lot of very serious
issues we've interviewed
like Mass murderers like Sammy the bull
and and so forth uh so I don't really
worry when it comes to doing my job my
job supersedes any level of concern or
fear or anything else like that and
ultimately you know if I ever feel there
is a situation where
there might be some danger I always move
with armed security
you you famously a very big fan of of
two packs there's of course millions of
people were and it remained one of the
great mysteries about this if it turns
out that your interviews have helped
lead to solving this mystery will you
feel a sense of uh closure for Tupac and
his family
well I mean for me the closure came four
years ago when I did the interview uh
there was a lot of conspiracy theories
when it comes to Tupac there was that
you know Shug had him set up there was
the government did it there was the
first responder had a body that he
switched the Tupac is living in Cuba
somewhere there's there's a lot of crazy
theories out there so for me when I did
the interview four years ago and we went
through the entire story you know really
kiefd's entire life story but really
leading up to what happened from Orlando
getting jumped at the mall to you know
the next few steps to them going to
Vegas to what happened you know during
the fight to what happened afterwards
that essentially
told the story you know I've been saying
for years that I solved I saw the Tupac
murder uh you know when it comes to the
family I've had various family members
uh reach out through people to say
they're very happy about it but the
thing about it is um
you know I I know people that were very
close to Tupac's mother Afeni Shakur and
they all told me that while she was
alive she did not care about the police
solving this case uh the Shakura family
had a very
you know
you know bad relationship with the
police like we run out of time I'm
pregnant I'm really sorry I'd love to
have done more of this thank you very
much for a great interview I've been
following you for a long time and you're
great at what you do and I congratulate
you on this thank you very much
[Music]
good night
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City King peers
and King Q I think there's only one for
one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous it was
clearly something of the face of the
world so it was even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
board she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katie that would make
her a better princess of wealth because
you're not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
[Music]
let it roll
oh yeah